qu'est ce qu'il a dit amer quand elle a
su tu peux appeler jean yves lafesse
pareil ça doit être terrible
voilà possible parce que ton bretagne
n'avait pas carbone 14
non pas vraiment madame survient sur du
zèle trafic des stupéfiants ce que vous
avez acheté des légumes aujourd'hui des
cas on peut voir s'il vous plaît vous
avez acheté l'un droite à gauche mais
oui oui vous en avez acheté combien le g
et à combien aujourd'hui et vous comptez
les utiliser pour vos fins domestiques
ou pour vous pour votre entourage pour
vérifier
rennes vainqueur autonome ses 40 ans
étaient trafiqués
regardez ce cas personnel elles ont été
trafiqués par la secte foule qui a
introduit dans les champs de carotte un
produit si nos jeunes qu'on appelle le
laisse diffusé lundi par idéalisme et
puis bon ce qui vise donc à intoxiquer
et à draguer les pros des populations
collective les collectivités en vous par
exemple vous avez vous mangez sur le
sommet dit oui vous comptez faire rap et
l'arabe
passé par là mon sac de madame
rappelez-vous carotte pour lui manger
non parce que c'est pas faire fuir
vous avez mangé quand la dernière fois
l'uni vertige santé alcaloïdes mon sport
ainsi nos gènes de santé ça fait 15
jours que j'ai été soumise à destination
vous avez fait des rêves des cauchemars
et les angoisses d'un petit problème
madame avec vous c'est qu'on vous
repèrent depuis tout à l'heure votre
comportement ressemble fort à celui d'un
dealer compagnie temps est-ce que vous
revendez par hasard ça
l'enfant de marche
on peut vérifier que depuis 15 jours n'a
vu aucune altération de votre
comportement d'un homme
hallucination
effet
qu'est ce qui pousse un pas comme ça
mais madame s'initiant la santé nous
sommes un peu tous ces trafics marchands
de carottes
combien de grammes aujourd'hui voilà
j'ai dû demander je croyais 500 g vient
nous faire peur que ça c'est pour une
seule et même personne
c'est énorme et je vous le dis on est
deux vous êtes le doublé toxiques et qui
se demandent maintenant non mairie en
maintenant les jours je me suis pour une
personne je suis avec mon père c'est non
mais ne vous faites pas des carottes
râpées pour tous les meubles
non je sais pour faire fuir des 40 donc
vous est ce qu'on appelle une fourmi un
petit dealer n'est pas au bout d'une
heure dans ce centre il s'intéresse à
vous le connaissez bien cette épice et
la méconnaissance vous aussi puissiez
côté là non parce que nous aussi les
gros dealer notamment contre soi que la
collaboration des populations civiles
si vous avez acheté les carottes qui
sont attendus tous les aider non madame
services et de vision il faut l'épreuve
je n'en sais rien mais paf vador dans la
drogue pour les carottes ont été
trafiqués la rive est interceptée dans
un cadeau madame vous avez vous aider
vous avez vous les avez osé dénoncer il
faut coincé madame simard si possible
quand est arrivée à europe 1 qu'as tu
appris la tranche de coluche que tu
avais quand même un peu assassinée chez
paul a quand même quand tu avais dit
collige tu nous fait plus rire c'était
un peu dur comme maintenant ouais mais
je l'aimais ouais
j'aimais vraiment il croit que c'est à
cause de toi qui s'est remis au travail
qu'il a fait il a fait tchao pantin non
les restos du coeur n'ont sûrement pas
non mais est ce que je chantais en lui
stand et reste un enfant c'est pour ça
que j'ai pensé qu'il était pas
simplement là ce soir là à droit de
réponse pour faire son numéro mais j'ai
voulu lui dire qu'il y avait des gens
qui l'aimaient pour ce qui montrait pas
là à ce moment là mais ce qu'on se
sentait en lui et effectivement une
italie beaucoup plus humain par la suite
mais j'étais pas le seul certainement
pas le seul elle pensait alors d'aller
j'en ai pas dormi pendant neuf mois
après à bon port après tales et sur
canal+ et tafer linverse du duo le bras
roulant tu as fais là la caméra visible
c'est à dire qu'on voyait la caméra et
chaque fois tu avais une excuse pour
dire aux gens pourquoi il y avait cette
caméra qui étaient là et tu t'es aperçu
que les gens finalement il était comme
tu dis cassé depuis l'enfance et à dire
que dès qu'il voit une caméra il avait
il était terrorisé il faisait tout ce
qu'on leur disait y balancer leurs
copains y balancer leurs voisins et
c'est pas un peu un regard pt trotskiste
wallon non mais je sais pas c'est pas un
peu un regard de dextrose car comme ça
sur la société non non je me fie plus à
une analyse idéologique ou mais cette du
cid é té ça vient de là quand même non
non non non j'ai toujours eue si tu veux
bonjour madame
est ce qu'on peut venir vous poser
quelques petites questions tout de suite
sur quoi venez je peux vous d'abord je
vous serre la main voilà comme ça
bougeait pas
vous explique je suis docteur story
revient d'un voyage en afrique d'une
mission à mogadiscio en somalie
vous savez qu'il ya des ravages qui sont
causés par la peste bubonique vous êtes
au courant de ça oui bon je vais
contacter et nous allons nous avons
besoin ne m'ont pas s'être cobayes nous
sommes obligés de faire des prélèvements
d'inoculer donc cette maladie à des gens
comme vous exagérez
non non non non mais attendez il faut il
faut qu'on dise il faut qu'on en
fabrique pour les africains pour la
barre donc ce que ce que je viens de
vous faire un hard c'est se transmet de
mère cutanée par tous les pores de la
peau à ça les deux côtés mais pourquoi
si vous faites ça et parce que vous ne
vous rendez pas compte qu'il va falloir
faire braquer du sérum montant de
quantité donc ces documents peuvent être
transmis à leurs immenses va prouver à
tous nos confrères européens de faire la
même chose dans leurs pays respectifs
c'est tout alors je vais vous donner ma
carte et des vous sentirez donc les deux
complètement non mais attendez attendez
écoutez moi je vous dis que j'ai le sida
ce que je vais arrêter le médicament que
je vous lis les articles l'attendait
d'abord vous allez prendre car il
voulait pas partir son premier corner
condamné mon cabinet mais vous êtes m'en
fous non mais attendez attendez pas ce
qu'on peux pas vous laisser dire ça
comme ça vous êtes malade là bas mais
chez toi vous êtes malade mais vous êtes
fous alors partez pas comme ça là vous
venez d'être malade vous êtes malade
écoutez moi je vous stop j'empêche tous
les gens de venir là au moins vous ne
vous ne pourrez plus touché les gens
qu'ils aiment à la mise en scène la 15e
personne on est obligé un objet fabriqué
et la msa à partir d'italie en
angleterre ils vont tous l'appareil je
suis obligé effectivement de ce n'est
les gens dont je m'occupe vous êtes
obligé madame attendait drive vient
d'écorner le cabinet sous les sony ou
pas voulez qu'on vous laisse partir
comme ça va avoir 40 de fièvre demain
écoutez vous êtes sûr que je vous
contacterai alors là pour bar évidemment
vas-y ray trouvé que ce moyen là
vous êtes vraiment des cons ah oui
comment on va fabriquer comment on va
faire du sérum je ne sais pas le
convaincre qu'il allait mal adapté les
gens les gens de chez moi un truc qu'on
vous avez pas honte de ce minerai sous
cette forme là mais c'est pas qu'on va
être convaincu il faut qu'on fabrique du
sérum mes demandes et du sérum en feu en
faisant des mais commence demain avant
en faisant quoi il faut bien qu'on
compte qu'on donne la maladie on sait
bien qu'on contamine on va vous soigner
vous inquiétez pas à ça se soigne mieux
maintenant complétée par la mairie le
mériteraient qu'une seule chose et je
vous fiche ma main sur la figure parce
toute façon et je signale que les
italiens les allemands le fond on est
obligé de le faire exister en plus
obligés de baver sur moi enfin il faut
bien qu'on gotta be
mais il faut bien qu'on contamine madame
vous vous rendez pas compte et les c'est
quand tu es parti sur sur tf1 pour faire
pirates s'étaient plutôt bien ce que
vous faisiez comment ça se fait que ce
soir était aussi aussi brutalement
je veux pas faire de délation non mais
je crois que tai shan avait absolument
pas réfléchi à la manière dont on allait
travailler
nous on est arrivé avec l'intimé
conviction qu'on allait pouvoir
effectivement fabriquer un 52 minutes
mensuel un peu livrés à nous mêmes comme
les monty python peut-être pas avec un
budget énorme mais au moins qu'on
pourrait travailler
l'imposture pour eux c'était quelque
chose de nouveau le détournement aussi
là pour être complètement tranquille tu
as fait un disque qui reprend les
meilleurs
les meilleurs sketches de repas tu sais
quand tu appelles quelqu'un quand on
entend le à lotus et comment elle mal
quoi
g si tu veux une intuition quand
j'appelle effectivement
des gens dans leur halo et qu'ils ont
une fonction ouais
j'entends leurs fonctions lalo d'une
secrétaire de direction n'est pas le
même que ceux d'une secrétaire et il
délivre un certain nombre d'informations
qui faut que j'analyse très vite et
c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui dans ce
pays c'est que les gens ont perdu
complètement conscience de leur être au
profit de leurs fonctions alors y en a
c'est un voyeur une bonne blague ce
serait un peu francis blanche ça quand
même un ouais mais ça s'appuie sur la
sur la délation
ouais c'est une bonne blague sur c'est
un mec qui téléphonent il dit voilà moi
ce soir je suis voyage habitants ouais
en espèces voilà est-ce que ce soir je
peux vous mater les jumelles ou à la
sécurité vous à poils à l'isr voilà vous
donne deux sens paray et le mec petit à
petit bond il refuse en plus il prend il
me prend pour un de ses voisins qui est
un prothésiste dentaire qui a l'habitude
depuis c'est par la fenêtre
donc il me vire il jette surtout quand
je propose le sens mal pour s'exiler
après évidemment il ya chez très francis
blanche et la police qui appelle en
disant il faut que vous fassiez il faut
que vous fassiez comme ça on va pouvoir
le coincer voilà mais le vrai hilarant
dira pas ce que lui demande de faire le
policier mais le mec le fait en tout les
mêmes de fait à la fin ce que je veux
juste te dire à propos de sa selle pour
pour expliquer pourquoi je rappelle les
gens quand je me fais passer par un
service de police tu sais que je suis
toujours au service des écoutes
téléphoniques est ce que tu sais que
j'ai le dos avec des mots tout leur
dicte tout antoine et le mec le croit
complet malawi
j'ai fait ça 40 fois certains et les
gens qui pensaient les gens à admettre
très bien qu'ils sont écoutés ils sont
écoutés j'aurais demande de parler plus
fort parce que on les entend pas bien
elle a besoin de régler le volume sonore
et les mecs parlent te raconte de
revivre les 42 42 complètement mais il
ya beaucoup d'improvisation par exemple
sur les tubes à une à 14 15
il ya beaucoup d'improvisation si un peu
quand tu appelles les gens tu sais pas
ce que tu vas leur dire c'est impossible
de le savoir je ne sais pas si je vais
avoir au bout du fil ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est je veux cette
possibilité de jongler avec tout
qui part simplement dus à l'eau et qui
arrive effectivement à des situations
une folle s'est laissé mon boulot je
sais faire que ça
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux